it should only count two here we go
we need a new rule that's wrong
adebayo duncan robinson again that's
good and the foul
duncan robinson from downtown what a
rookie year he's having in his first
playoff series
big shot with the time crowder by the
way davis picked up that
last laker foul that's his first lakers
by three
tyler hero nice little fake duncan
robinson has some room again that's two
three-pointers
three gives them another guy
that can spread out the size of one go
down you
feel like oh this is my day so this is
the first one off the jimmy butler just
again this just in a hero is more than a
sandwich
tyler getting it done no fear whatsoever
well he comes off to score every time
picks up the loose ball
still things shot second quarter he's
able to get a goal and it's tyler
prouder gets the finish and how about
this play by
tyler truly playing robinson continues
to knock down
shots early in this ball game as a shoot
we got to get one off here
great job getting back square and look
at just robinson's movement look how
he's keeping space and then boom as soon
as you turn around and you start
watching
the defender the offensive player in the
post look what he does and bam at the
top of the key
as a big man no one does it better the
big fella look at this miscommunication
right here on defense and what happens
when that that's a loose play a broken
play like you called it and
how about iguodala in this shot
it's not just the fearlessness it's the
skill set that's getting them on the
floor
just efficient use of the dribble pump
fake side step
yes basketball he sees the big he says
all right
i'm gonna protect with my body make the
left hand that is tough
wow coming to his right strong hand he's
like okay giannis has come to me i know
the read
whoever said a hero ain't nothing but a
sandwich is a liar he's a knock down
shooter and put his team in position
and just don't think tyler hero is a
three-point shooter this is a guy that
could take the ball off the bouncy
first off that high screen and roll
throws it straight to the glass
finish and then takes the shot to the
head the concentration
and the uses of the left hand tyler hero
putting on a show the way he's played
down here in orlando it feels like
that's going to change and it doesn't
matter where robinson is on the floor
he said he battled impostor syndrome
imposter that's a shooter right
there 39 minutes more because duncan
robinson has not been on the floor but
boy he's
i mean this is just simple basketball
and i'm gonna eat i'm gonna continue to
run it until they figure it out
because this is bad weak side defense
and you can think
the sprint behind by robinson
well good strip by crowder advances it
to hiro and then just the pull-up three
is
pure better offense one-on-one
elevates i call that hero balls
you see where hero does turns to corner
spectacular finish
with that left hand gets the beautiful
bounce you know you could shoot the
basketball but
the surprising thing is how comfortable
he is
i mean like mark was saying just good
pace good rhythm
good use of the rim rookie i want him
brought out to half court
and given first team all rookie
i think that's his fourth but brown goes
under against robinson
miami gets back and gets a fairly good
contest but that's a lot of space
fonts by the heat the deflection and
then
tyler hero the blow-by taking the
contact
and finishing anyway the hero does a
good job pushing the basketball
gets the contact gets the hoop rondo
praying trying to get at the ball great
job by
hero i'm not sure you're snarling
i i'm not sure this is just a beautiful
finish
takes davis off the dribble left doesn't
even bring it back to the other hand
butler guarded by morse
shot clock at four butler drives stops
up top robinson puts up a three
it's good it's good hero with seven to
shoot
hiro long three-pointer bang tyler hero
from way downtown wow
heat back by eight trying to win the
series
we step aside on tnt